- Dragon fruit.
(inspirational music)
(calming music)
PureWow mafia, Mary Kay and Ryan.
Anyway, nonetheless, Babin and I
have done a bad job this morning.
So what'd I do, I worked
out, I had a meeting
with Matt Higgins, with
the Steven Ross crew there,
my business partner, I went
and met a new potential client,
I did a couple phone calls,
we announced Michael Badgley,
our signed kicker from
the University of Miami,
it's all about the U.
And now I'm here with PureWow
to make things happen.
- Is it three?
How much money?
'Cause I don't wanna --
- We're still figuring it out ourselves.
- Got it.
- And the truth is, it
doesn't work that way.
One video can change everything.
Do you understand --
- You can't contest it against something.
So you're betting on the one --
- My man, you're making
television commercials,
the only difference is,
there's more attention,
and you get more at bat's.
There's three things that are happening.
You're getting more at bat's,
you're getting three instead of one,
a lot more people are seeing it
so it can penetrate culture,
and the client is paying a lot less for it
than they would have in the alternative.
That's why it's right.
It doesn't go beyond that, got it?
You wanna hear something amazing?
We only have ancillary beat the hero.
We do a vlog, it never gets
seen as much as the one minute
clips we get out of the vlog.
- That makes total sense.
- Only ancillary beats.
Now, this is very long form.
- Yup.
- Three minute videos are actually,
actually, I retake my thing
'cause if I was to make
a three minute rant right now,
it would beat out the ancillary.
- Yup.
- Like I made the greatest video ever that
would have gotten a hundred
fifty million views,
but Babin didn't have audio
in the Milwaukee airport.
- [Man] Are you serious?
- That's right vlog, the greatest video --
- It was Australia.
The greatest video I ever
made that would have been my
true 200 million viewed video on Facebook,
Babin fucked up.
- Oh guys, want your pen?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I got it.
- If you could tell Dana that
we're gonna meet late tonight
about cocktails, that'd be great.
- About cocktails --
do we have--
- How are you doin'?
Thank you, I didn't
want to just jump in --
- No worries. What's your name?
- It's Regina.
- Regina, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Have a great day.
Oh my god, I have such
a tagline for our brand.
Hi low. Fuck the middle.
(laughs)
But that's what it is.
The middle --
- Fuck in a tagline.
- But that's like what my belief is.
- [Man] It's really good.
(laughs)
- That's what it is though,
the middle is where everybody's losing.
Like that's where everybody's losing.
Yo, whaddup Team Gray V account.
It's me, Gary V.
In Vegas, doin' my thing at CS.
Babin's hustlin'.
It's gonna be back, 2018.
I'm gonna fuckin' dismantle 2018.
You think we did work in '17?
Fuckin' '18.
What's up man, how are you?
Yeah, real quick.
- Gary V. 'Preciate you, dog.
- Take care, brother.
(elevator buzzing)
Just going to a meeting at babbycan film,
that's all we're doin'.
- Dude.
- Dude, pleasure to meet
you, Shawn Gunn man.
- Hey Shawn, how are you?
- Can I take a picture with you?
- 100%.
- Aw man.
- My man.
- Perfect.
Keep doin' it, keep doin' it.
- Take care of yourself, I will. Stay low.
Anyway, how you doin'?
- Good man, good.
I didn't know you were gonna be out here,
I was just here, I was doing
a couple speaking engagements.
I think it was like Homie was like,
"Is Gary out there?"
- That's a good question.
- Probably.
(laughs)
I mean shit, let's see him
face to face if we're here
and you could spend the
time, I appreciate you--
- Yeah, as soon as I
knew you were available,
I canceled some stuff.
- "Hey listen, I'm 18 years old,"
he's like, "I'm on this Gary V thing,"
he goes "I'm right there with you,"
he goes "when I was 14,"
he goes "I coked with Gary V."
And he goes "I've been through
some issues with school"
and blah blah blah,
long story short, I gave
him a 20 minute meeting
goes "changed my life."
I mean he's now 18 and runs this company,
and he's got, he goes "I've
got this entrepreneur house
I'm doing at South by Southwest,
I want K-Swiss to be part of it."
He goes, "I'm not gonna charge you."
- Man, that's just so real.
- And he goes, "I just
want you to be involved
because 20 of my partners are there,
we're all entrepreneurs,"
And he goes, "we're gonna create content."
And I said, "Done, let's go, we're in."
Isn't it amazing?
That was four years ago.
14, this kid's 18 now.
And he's comin' up to me,
I mean when I was 18,
I wasn't going up to
people like that and say "Hey,
give me your business card."
And he's giving me value for free.
He said right off the bat like,
I'm not gonna charge you because I'm like
"Oh right, I'm not interested."
- I'm teaching them how to win.
It's so much bigger than
people realize. Okay.
(techno music)
Hi guys, hi hi hi.
Come on in.
We go look at culture and the consumer,
and we put out a two minute,
14 second cartoon of --
'cause that's what the fuck we decided?
I could've sold that to her in that moment
for two thousand off a
separate piece of her budget,
I know it, but I didn't have the tool --
I know how I sell, and I know
that there's opportunities,
and I wanna have a product to sell.
But like whatever it is,
and it might be one to three
products, it might be one product,
it might be a way we talk,
but by south by, definitely by can,
the three of us are talkin'
the same language-ish.
You know, we alter it
to the moment in time.
But the three of us are
talking the same language,
and it just becomes habit.
Because I've got the history
and I understand where
I'm taking it, so.
What up vlog, tryin' to use
my phone more this year.
We're headin' out, we're here in Vegas.
Kickin' Babin out 'cause
I got a MediaLink party
and then after meetings, no
reason to have him hang out.
I'm gonna let him go
have some fuckin' fun.
'Cause you know, Babin in
Vegas creates a serious
combination of fuckin' fun.
So while he's goes has fun,
I'm gonna go fuckin' create foundational
experiences --
I'm just gonna go fuckin' work.
It's as simple as that.
(techno music)